[Music]
so lastly i'm going to go over sample
quantification
and qc so sequencing can be really
really expensive so it's really
important that you check your libraries
before you put them on the sequencer
because once you spent that money and
if the samples were poor you spent money
on
and weren't able to you wouldn't be able
to get much data out of it and so there
are different
qc methods but most of them will check
the size distribution of the samples
and there are a couple different
instruments that you can use to do this
so these include the agilent bioanalyzer
tape station fragment analyzer there's a
system from
kyogen called the kaixel and another one
from perkin elmer called the lab chip
and there are others out there as well
we do have a another ibiology video
about how to use and analyze data from
the bioanalyzer
if you want to get some more details
about that process
lastly after qc you also want to
quantify your samples again most times
people aren't sequencing a single sample
they're sequencing multiple samples
and they want relatively equal numbers
of sequencing representation from each
of those samples
and this requires you to accurately
quantify those individual samples so
that you can make an even pull
that goes on to the sequencer and the
methods that are most commonly used are
qpcr
or digital pcr and also fluorometric
approaches such as the qubit or pico
green
taking advantage of uh fluorescent
properties of certain dyes
i highly recommend not using something
like a nano drop
because it's a it's an absorbent based
method that's not very quantitative
uh in the range of concentrations that
dna libraries usually come in so i would
avoid using a nano drop and stick with
one of these methods here
so i get a lot of questions about how to
do or analyze sample qc data especially
things that come
off of these capillary electrophoresis
methods like the bioanalyzer
and so i'm going to take a few moments
to go over what some of the
examples look like and so these
capillary electrophoresis methods will
show you a size distribution of your dna
sample
and so usually you have some plot that
looks like this where you have
fluorescence on the y-axis
and then size of your libraries or your
samples
on the x-axis and within each sample
there's usually a standard that gets
spiked into your sample
and so this usually includes a low
marker and a high marker
that are used as references so these
standards will get added to your sample
and then they get run
and a typical library will look like
this you have your lower and upper
markers or
standards that show up and then your
actual dna library will look like this
because you have different size inserts
you don't get a sharp peak you have some
distribution
and so this is a reasonably looking
library that
you know ranges from you know 150 or 200
bases
out to about under a thousand bases and
this is generally the
the size range that you're looking for
for these
aluminum next generation sequencing
libraries sometimes you might see
a short peak that's around 130 bases
especially if you're using these trusex
style library prep methods and what that
is is that's an adapter dimer
so this is a molecule that doesn't have
an insert in gray
it's just two adapters that have ligated
onto each other
it's empty and there's essentially no
dna of interest in there and if you see
this you'll generally want to go ahead
and then do another
base cleanup taking advantage of that
size selection property of the beads
so that you can enrich for your
libraries that have an
insert and get rid of those adapter
dimers and a reason to get rid of
adapter dimers is that they'll take up
space on your sequencer
and you're not going to get any usable
data so essentially it's a waste of your
sequencing if you have that in your
sample
other issues you might see if you see a
kind of a smear on the very low end
close to that lower marker
usually that means you have primer
contamination in your sample
and if you see that that's generally
something you want to get rid of because
this can interfere
with some of the sequencing reactions
and
and cause problems especially have bar
coded samples that you're pulling
together so you definitely want to get
rid of those and again you can use
these bead-based cleanups to selectively
get rid of these smaller fragments
with next hair libraries sometimes you
wind up with a longer or wider
distribution that looks like this
and this is okay to go on the sequencer
and it's just a property of this nextera
process if you
are interested in a specific size range
again you can use those beads
to generate a tighter distribution and
you can shift that size range
to the appropriate size for your needs
lastly something very common that i see
are something called bubble products
these look like they have a reasonably
sized library over here but they have
a secondary peak that's about twice the
size
and what happens here is that you may
have over amplified your library so that
you run out of primers and so what
happens is
through downstream pcr cycles
your samples get denatured but because
there are no
primers to kind of complete the next
round of extension
these molecules will come back together
and they'll hybridize by the adapter
sequences but chances are
molecules aren't going to find the
matching insert dna they'll bind to some
other piece of library
so you get a bubble product where at the
ends the adapters are binding but the
inserts are not binding in the middle
and this will generally lead to a
fraction that shows up twice the size
and these are okay the sequence as well
but just something to to be aware of and
it's
it's generally okay to sequence those
samples
so in summary you know to prepare dna
libraries you have to isolate your dna
or your rna from your samples and then
you have to convert that material
into a library and this means adding
adapters onto properly sized inserts
and again many molecular biology enzymes
can be used for this process i've only
covered a couple of different methods
there are many many methods many
different kits out there and some have
certain advantages so if you have
a specific need i would contact you know
your dna sequencing facility at your
local campus and they can give you
suggestions
on some of the best methods to use for
your application and lastly
i want to definitely stress this is that
you want to quantify and check the
quality of your libraries before you
sequence them
just because you know the process can be
expensive and you want to make sure that
you get the best data possible and make
sure that your samples look good before
you sequence them